[Music]
it's just one of those days when I wake
up too late with the sun in my face and
I'm wa it it's just one of those days
that I wish I could eras but I got a few
ways I can
wasted screaming through the walls ain't
nobody sleeping I don't want to talk I
just want to sleep and woke up to a text
from my ex-girlfriend saying she in love
with my old best friend acting like it's
cool it was way back then yeah I'm over
it everything was good I was on my
I got all messed up and it made me sick
everything was good I was on my
I'll be better soon and get back to it
just want to those days when I wake up
too late with the sun in my face and I'm
wasted it's just one of those days that
I wish I could have R but I've got a few
ways I can Wast
it I could order Postmates smoke a lot
of weed and watch another season 13
Reasons now I'm going through some pigs
on my ex-girlfriend she ain't really
high like she was back then I don't
really care cuz I'm over it I'm over it
yeah everything was good I was on my
I got all messed up and it made me
sick everything was good I was on my
I'll be better soon and get back to
it it's just one of those days when I
wake up too late with the sun in my face
and I'm wasted it's just one of those
days that I I wish I couldn't erace but
I got a few ways I could waste
[Music]
it
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that flow
video uh that site is actually one that
I just randomly found uh walking around
this past weekend so um yeah pretty cool
to find uh out of the way graffiti spots
like that here in the city and uh made
for a great video uh I hope you enjoyed
it real quickly I just want to put a
huge thank you out there to ultra poy
for sponsoring this video and giving me
a reason to get out in DC and discover
cool new spots like that if you'd like
to grab a set of those orb poy Pros that
I was using in this video you can go
ahead and do that by heading on over to
ultra.com and using the promo code Drex
factor with a zero instead of an O at
checkout that gets you a discount on
your order and it helps out the channel
so everybody wins once again that is
Drex factor with a zero instead of an O
over at ultra.com thank you once again
to ultra for sponsoring this video and
speaking of thank yous I owe thank yous
to the Friends of the channel that is
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyot
teror light toys spinballs and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- buus friend of the
channel That is Becca Becken thank you
so very much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission finally this
video would not be possible were not for
the awesome support of those who have
signed up to support this channel over
on patreon in particular I would love to
give a shout out to my flow patrons who
are listed on screen right now um if you
enjoyed this video and you'd like to see
more like it in the future if you enjoy
the work that I do creating videos about
flow arts and pois spinning and bringing
them to the whole wide world the way
that you can make sure that I get to
keep on doing that is to go over to my
patreon and sign up at HTTP
patreon.com drexfactor pooy supporting
me in this way means that I don't have
to go search for other things like
private lessons and the like to be able
to pay rent and I can focus more time on
creating videos so go check that out
please and thank you um if you'd like to
check out some of my other performance
videos I will include a link to a
playlist of those videos down in the
description as well as uh up on screen
if you're watching on YouTube thanks so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care now peace